they'll have to work it out because
nobody really wants a war
not the russians not the ukrainians
[Music]
the united states just stay out of it i
think
we shouldn't get them all
as a us citizen we shouldn't get
involved into other people's business
ukraine should be uh
they should fight for it putin is doing
what he always does
he's trying to regain as much territory
as he can with like the least amount of
bloodshed and he'll push it as much you
know as far as
as long as somebody says stop
you know
earlier these two country was together
always was together sometimes
mostly conflicts local conflicts
because
whoever you understand it's their
problems it's not very
interesting for both sides especially
for russia
so i hope everything will be fine but
i'm still
nervous about that i think they should
fight back for their country
i think the conflict itself is is kind
of uh
stupid since ukraine is
a partner you know whatever they should
do whatever they can to support them
you know because i'm sure they signed
some kind of treaty to to that effect
united states uh
what can they do i hope everything is
gonna be all right again if the people
want to be on the russian flag then they
should you know respect the people's
choice but okay that's up to people i
guess it doesn't make any sense because
we're
really too close cultures and i think we
should be
more friendly towards each other it's
almost conflict of our conflict
actually i'm really scared about that
and i don't want that
something will happen but actually i
think no no but nothing will happen but
they should be brotherly sort of like
yeah like brothers